Anfang Oktober in Berlin
hunderte vor allem junge Ärzte und
Ärztinnen streiken vor der
Universitätsklinik Charité sie wollen
damit auf ihre unzumutbaren
Arbeitsbelastungen aufmerksam machen
Überstunden fehlende Planbarkeit bei
Diensten kaum Pausen hier mit
ten auf die Worte nicht mit uns ich
liebe meinen Beruf wirklich aber wie
soll ich meinen Beruf lieben wenn er nur
aus Arbeitsverdichtung steht wenn der
adäquate versorgen meine
Intensivpatienten kaum mehr zu
gewährleisten ist der Intensivmediziner
Tim Arnold wenige Wochen nach dem Streik
er kommt gerade von seiner Nachtschicht
16 Stunden hat er gearbeitet
durchschnittlich verbringt der 65
Stunden die Woche in der Klinik oft ohne
Pausen wir haben eine wahnsinnig hohe
Verantwortung sogar unmittelbar in einer
lebensbedrohlichen Situation und
trotzdem gibt es bei uns keine
arbeitszeitbegrenzung Piloten die 16
Stunden am Stück arbeiten und vielleicht
sogar per Telefon anderen Piloten noch
erklären wie sie landen und ständig für
weitere Anfragen zur Verfügung steht
dass das wäre ein Flugzeug und dass wir
uns nicht einsetzen wollen würden
sechs Jahre dauerte die
Facharztausbildung jetzt ist Tim Arnold
40 Jahre alt und fragt sich wie lange er
diesen Job noch durchhält
man gibt seinen Privatleben auf und ist
eigentlich durchgehend nur noch für den
Beruf da und all das führt natürlich zu
einer gewissen privaten Isolation auch
nur über mehr Personal sowohl ärztlich
als auch pflegerisch können wir es
schaffen diese Arbeitsverdichtung die in
den letzten Jahren erheblich zugenommen
hat abzufangen
die Stimmung ist mies unter den Ärzten
ein Viertel der Angestellten Mediziner
denkt über einen Ausstieg aus dem Beruf
nach zu diesem alarmierenden Ergebnis
kommt der Marburger Bund in seiner
neusten Umfrage wir werden ja in den
nächsten Jahren schon allein dadurch
dass Ärzte im Babyboomer-Generation aus
dem Beruf ausscheiden Ärzte verlieren
wenn wir noch weitere verlieren ist das
wirklich schlimm
das Sankt Antonius Hospital in
Eschweiler hier auf der Intensivstation
kennen Sie das Problem enormer
Arbeitsbelastung es fehlt Pflegepersonal
Ärztinnen und Ärzte kommen an ihre
Grenzen die Corona herbstwelle
verschärfe die ohnehin prekäre Situation
das eigentliche Problem sei aber ein
anderes sagt Chefarzt Uwe Jansens das
Gesundheitswesen ist krank ist chronisch
krank und das ist auch eine Folge einer
Überstauung des Gesundheitssystems die
auf Ökonomie ausgerichtet ist Folge des
fallpauschalsystems was tatsächlich
operative Leistungen deutlich mehr
vergütet als ich sag mal überspitzt
Zuwendungen das persönliche Gespräch die
personalintensive Versorgung
schwerkranker Menschen sei ein Verlust
bringendes Geschäft und so verleitet
dieses System dazu vor allem die
Behandlungen durchzuführen die viel Geld
bringen oft am Wohlergehen der Patienten
vorbei
Ergebnis des fahrpauschalsystems was
tatsächlich vergütet wie lange jemand
beatmet wird und nicht belohnt wenn
Beatmungen verkürzt werden wenn man
tatsächlich Therapieverfahren wählt die
ausschließlich dem Wohl des Patienten
dem
abrechnen dürfen Kliniken nur Leistungen
die sie vorher dokumentiert haben das
erfordert viel Zeit jedes Detail muss
akribisch aufgeführt werden Zeit die für
die Patienten fehlt im Evangelischen
Krankenhaus in Herne arbeitet der
Assistenzarzt dr Moritz Völker der Junge
Anästhesist verbringt Stunden mit
bürokratischen Tätigkeiten
ich dokumentiere gerade die Medikation
des Patienten für den nächsten Tag das
muss sie jeden Tag neu gemacht werden
leider sind die medikamentenpläne noch
nicht digitalisiert das bedeutet das
wird jeden Tag neue händisch gemacht und
ja ist einer von vielen Zeitfressern
neben der notwendigen Dokumentation zum
Schutz der Patienten verbringt er vor
allem Zeit mit ausufernden
abrechnungsanforderungen ein ganz absurd
wird es tatsächlich wenn es eine
kritische Situation ist wo ich
eigentlich jede Hand brauche wo wir den
Patienten viele Blutprodukte geben
müssen da brauche ich einen Arzt nur
dafür dass er dokumentiert was man da
gibt das ist sehr sehr viel doppelt und
dreifach checken und alles immer wieder
neu begründen und halt aufschreiben
alles händisch
laut Umfrage verbringen angestellte
Ärzte mehr als drei Stunden am Tag mit
Dokumentation die bürokratische Last sei
viel zu hoch beklagt auch der Marburger
Bund der schon lange auf eine Lösung
trinkt
die hohe Belastung in den Krankenhäusern
für Ärzte und Ärzte kann tatsächlich
sehr schnell und sogar ja Kosten neutral
durch einen Abbau von
Dokumentationspflichten erreicht werden
wenn wir die Zeit nur halbieren hätten
wir ja plötzlich viel mehr ärztliche
Arbeitszeit für die Patienten zur
Verfügung
das Problem hat auch die Bundesregierung
erkannt im Koalitionsvertrag heißt es
Zitat durch ein bürokratieabbaupaket
bauen wir Hürden für eine gute
Versorgung der Patientinnen und
Patienten ab
doch das sogenannte
bürokratieabbaupaket lässt auf sich
warten wir fragen nach bei
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach für ein Interview mit frontal
steht er nicht zur Verfügung
in der berufsgenossenschaftlichen
Unfallklinik in Frankfurt am Main geht
man andere Wege Professor Steinfeld
Chefarzt für Anästhesie kämpfte um den
Nachwuchs für die Klinik
ich habe vor anderthalb Jahren hier in
Frankfurt angefangen und da war es
tatsächlich so dass hier einfach
Unmengen an Personal fehlte und da war
für mich völlig klar wir kriegen nur
Personal oder ich bekomme die Ärzte
wirklich nur hierher an die BGU
Frankfurt wenn wir Dinge anbieten die es
anderswo nicht gibt
flache Hierarchien zum Beispiel flexible
Arbeitszeiten wenn möglich die Belastung
bleibt trotzdem hoch doch die
Weiterbildung ist hier festgeschrieben
das kommt bei dem medizinischen
Nachwuchs gut an wenn man das Gefühl hat
man kriegt dafür aber viel zurück und
lernt dadurch viel dann ist man
natürlich eher bereit als wenn man
eigentlich das Gefühl hat man ist nur
das Arbeitstier und macht die niedere
Arbeit und profitiert dabei eigentlich
nicht selber
doch dazu braucht es sehr viel Anleitung
durch erfahrene Mediziner die diese
Kapazitäten haben müssen
das kostet auch uns einfach jeden Tag
viel Kraft und Zeit das ist einfach so
ich brauche auch die Geschäftsführung
hinter mir die dann auch sagt du kriegst
das Personal du kannst das Personal
einstellen was du brauchst da müssen
alle an einem Strang ziehen
berufsgenossenschaftliche Krankenhäuser
wie das in Frankfurt finanzieren sich
aus der gesetzlichen Unfallversicherung
und sind deshalb finanziell anders
aufgestellt doch eine krankenhausreform
sei längst überfällig sagen sie auch
hier dazu muss die Politik sich aber
auch mal entscheiden welche Kliniken
sind denn systemrelevant aus Sicht der
Politik momentan ist es so dass die
Kliniken alle kaputt gespart werden und
damit natürlich das System wenn es so
weitergeht in den nächsten Jahren vor
die Wand fahren wird
dabei verschlingt das Gesundheitssystem
Milliarden an Krankenkassenbeiträgen
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
verspricht jetzt die größte
krankenhausreform seit 20 Jahren eine
von ihm eingesetzte Kommission arbeitet
daran eine große Reform der
fahrpauschale Überwindung der
fahrpauschale habe ich ja angekündigt
daran arbeiten wir seit Monaten auf
Nachfrage erklärt das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium was das
konkret für die Krankenhäuser bedeuten
soll
das Finanzierungssystem hat sich
überholt die ökonomischen Anreize sind
zu stark das wollen wir überwinden und
nicht alle sollen alles machen wir
wollen die allgemeine Versorgung in der
Fläche und die Spezialisten in den
Zentren
[Musik]
der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat viel vor
aber Fachleute haben Zweifel dass diese
Reform wirklich gelingt ich glaube es
braucht unbedingt eine Beteiligung der
Akteure die auch nachher in der
Umsetzung beteiligt sind das Feedback
ist das eigentlich gangbar funktioniert
das in der Fläche ist das gut fürs
Krankenhauspersonal dieser Dialog muss
dringend geführt werden
Krankenhausärzte wie Tim Arnold
verschaffen sich nun selbst Gehör sie
fordern endlich Lösungen von der Politik
ein Arzt muss ja eine psychische und
eine emotionale Gesundheit mitbringen um
vernünftig arbeiten zu können und das
ist natürlich unter diesen
Voraussetzungen überhaupt nicht gegeben
und solange sich das nicht ändert
überlegen immer mehr Mediziner den
Kliniken endgültig den Rücken zu kehren